well first I'm gonna say I think I
should be your father all those on here
[Music]
what's up y'all window color doing here
I got $15 to pick my all-time do squad
I feel like Coach K builds a culture
there you know they hold Brotherhood day
really sticks with us and everybody
wants to be a part of it I'm gonna
probably go with Kyrie you know that's
fine I was out there takes his time the
step back and just the fadeaway and it
just looks so effortless I mean the name
kind of speak for herself
I'm saying he's been doing this thing
ever since he got in the league okay
I'll probably go at Barbra jumped three
four times everybody else jumped once
maybe twice I going Bobby just because I
mean he's so versatile that's a big to
play both pile for that Center and I
went to school yeah man I'm probably
going a J also actually I take away I
take away JJ and I put Jason fatal shot
I mean no space to work
nickimja three what to - I'll say Jason
instead of Daisy I'm switched it Jason
he's very versatile get knocked down
open shot and get to the cuff whenever
he wants to
great footwork great great footwork I'll
go with Jalil you know that's my guy
no hold it down in the paint you know he
did a standard Duke for sure don't wanna
go no where'd it go cut off the weight
and then that's when I probably go with
Grayson it's because I play Widow I know
already well very very scrappy just
shoot the ball here and walk boys to us
[Music]
I'm window Carly Julia this is my
all-time Duke squat I got Grayson Allen
Marvin Bagley Jalil Okafor Jason Statham
Kyrie Irving same thing work up get a
step back that is Kyrie sweet spot
[Music]